Chúng ta không thông báo hợp những nhà là pháp Mỹ bộ ngoại sông Mỹ cho biết đang cửa nha m in bên tạm thời tới Caracas,
để thực hiện các trưng năng ngoại sà của chọn lập theo kia hoạch, để lửa bước đi đầu tiên trong lỗ trình từng dây đoạn.
Nhằm khôi phục hoàn toàn hoạt động của đại su quán Mỹ tại videozilla,
cơ quan đã đón cửa từ tháng 3 năm hành hình không trong mấy chính.
Thông báo đưa ra trường bối cảnh ngoại trường như Raccoon Biow sự kiến yêu chân,
cho bối bán đối ngoại trường việc về chính sách đối với videozilla,
điều này đời hỏi Washington sẽ cần xem sách điều chính lập trường công nhận chính trị,
bối Caracas, theo bộ ngoại sông Mỹ trong gia đình đầu,
khăn nha ngoại sàu sẽ tập trung những buồn anh ninh gọc hoa liy,
sau đó sẽ mở giọc xam cơ liy bất lãnh sử, chính trị, kinh tảy và ngoại sà không trúng.
Vậy, viện với New Zealand,
thông thông lắm thời, đêm xuyên vô đu quế trường biết,
Caracas và Washington đã thiết là cơ tên nha là khăn tính tôn trọng,
và xây dự đồng thông một,
và thật định chính phố videozilla đang làm việc với chính quyền Mỹ
nhằm sách trị của chúng trình nghĩ sử hợp tác,
cho bối cảnh 2 bên tìm cách kẻ thịt quanh hệ sông cơm.